in the aftermath of a mass shooting in
colorado the left trots out its usual
propaganda about gun control
and whiteness but the evidence just
isn't there plus joe biden pushing
massive change but just how fast i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
slash ben will get to all the news of
the day in just one second first the
word is how people are abandoning their
overpriced wireless carriers
and flocking to pure talk for the same
coverage but at a fraction of the price
that's right if you're with verizon att
or t-mobile switching to pure talk could
save your family over 800
a year and switching is easy you can
keep your phone keep your number or get
huge discounts on the latest iphones and
androids
i got the iphone 12 i love it i'm
getting the same great coverage but for
half
the price right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks
a month which is a fantastic deal so
here's the thing the other
wireless carriers they're going to
charge you up the wazoo because they're
going to say that you needed limited
data you don't need unlimited data what
you actually need is the deal that pure
talk is about to give you
unlimited talk tech six gigs of data
because if you go over on the data
they're not even going to charge you for
it there's a reason pure talk is the
highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs
stop giving your money to overpriced
wireless carriers start saving money
today
from your cell phone pound 250 say ben
shapiro you'll save 50
off your very first month that is pound
two five zero say ben shapiro dial pound
250 right now say keyword ben shapiro
and you will get 50
off your first month and save hundreds
of bucks down the road pure talk is
simply
smarter wireless alrighty so in the
aftermath of this horrific shooting in
colorado
the left went into an almost mechanistic
call for gun control i'll say just like
clockwork every time
there is a mass shooting and that mass
shooting particularly
is is a mass shooting that cannot be
blamed on white supremacy
they make it about gun control right so
there's a certain formula left likes to
use
if a mass shooting is performed by a
person who is not white they talk about
gun control
if the mass shooting is performed by a
person who is white they talk about
white supremacy with like a little taste
of gun control
well right now it turns out that the
shooter in this particular case was not
white he was apparently
a syrian immigrant who had serious
mental illness
problems and so this became immediately
a call
for gun control and understand that the
call for gun control for the media
is based on emotional appeal it is not
based on
a factually reasoned argument in favor
of gun control why gun control would
work in a country that already has 300
million guns in circulation
it is not a case that makes any sort of
logical sense any evidentiary sense
instead it is a case that is solely and
completely driven by
a desire to cram down a moral premise on
the rest of the world which is that if
you disagree with the left then this
means that in some way
you're morally deficient this is the
case members of the media make and the
way they make it
is by getting very emotional on tv now
i'm not denying that people
on tv the people you watch every night
get emotional about stories
all i'm pointing out is they they only
get emotional about certain stories
right they don't get emotional every
time they talk about violence in chicago
over the weekend which they barely talk
about at all
and there's ongoing violence in chicago
every weekend dozens of people shot
every single weekend in chicago
and they don't seem to care very much
about that you don't see people welling
up on tv over that but every time
there's a mass shooting
that is that is not to be blamed on sort
of the regular dose of violence that you
see in america's major cities
if we're not talking about the increased
murder rate around america's major
cities that is largely driven by lack of
police
then they start to get very emotional so
you'll see anchors get very emotional
about the george floyd situation but you
won't see anchors get emotional
about small children being shot in the
middle of gangland wars in chicago or
washington dc or los
angeles and you won't see anybody mourn
the folks
who are dying because there's lack of
police in these cities so the emotion is
part of the agenda
again the emotion can be genuine and
also part of the agenda i'm not
questioning the genuineness of the cnn
anchors when they get very sad about
mass shootings
because we should all be very sad about
mass shootings all i'm pointing out is
the performance of the performative
sadness that you see
on your nightly newscast is in fact
connected to a political agenda
what they choose to air in terms of
their own
emotional vulnerability is deeply
connected to the idea that if you don't
agree with them on policy it's because
you are uncaring
and that's what happened last night on
cnn you had brian brianna keller and
of cnn and stephanie elam near tears on
cnn over the mass shooting again i'm not
doubting the sincerity of their emotion
i'm just pointing out that the emotion
only appears on tv with regard to
particular kinds of stories
because it is being used as a as a wedge
in order to suggest that if you don't
agree with cnn's preferred solutions you
just don't care enough about bad things
happening
you know stephanie i'm as i'm hearing
you report this i just wonder
can you count how many times you've
covered a story like this
have you lost count i don't i don't
know anymore and it makes me sad it
makes me sad to even sit here and think
about that
brianna that there's been so many times
that we have had to go out
and cover these stores and talk to
people who
are devastated okay so here is the thing
in the united states every year there
are over 19 000 homicides in the united
states every single year
the number of people who are killed in
mass shootings in the united states
every year
is generally i mean any number any one
of these is obviously a tragedy it
should never happen
we all agree okay but the number of
people who are killed in
mass shootings of this kind these sort
of spectacular on tv blanket coverage
mass shootings
it's probably not even 100 a year in
terms of these kinds of shootings
okay but the way that the the way that
the media
treat these shootings as opposed to the
other 19 000 homicides that happen
every single year in the united states
it does tell you something about their
approach
to these issues so the left will tell
you for example that the right
focuses farts when there's a terror
attack the right will focus far too much
on the terror attacks because your risk
of actually dying in a terror attack is
pretty low
your risk of dying in a mass shooting in
a country of 330 million people
is actually quite low okay your risk of
being killed in a generalized homicide
is higher
even that is pretty low in the united
states which is not which is a
overall a pretty safe country but the
way the media cover this stuff
is is to suggest that these particular
shootings are a grave threat
to every single american citizen right
this is
anecdotal anecdotal data being presented
as as
systemic data in the same way that the
george floyd death
was presented as systemic police
violence even though
we don't know that it actually was
racist even though we still have to find
out whether it was in fact a homicide or
not that was presented
as systemic even though the data don't
support that
mass shootings are presented as systemic
even though the data really don't
support that
and not only that because they're
presented as systemic the idea is that
this is a high priority for the united
states and it requires
massive restraint in order to massively
restrict the individual rights of
americans to keep and bear arms under
the second amendment you have to say
that this is such a grave threat to the
life and liberty of americans that it
justifies an encroachment
on one of the fundamental rights held by
330 million americans
and so you have to you have to say that
the threat is supremely grave
not just that these incidents are active
evil that the people who commit them
should be punished that we should take
every measure available without invading
individual rights in order to stop them
that's not enough
because what left wants to do here is to
invade your right
and so what you have is the media
attempting to play up the idea that this
stuff is happening like all the time
in the united states so you have a piece
from philip bump over at the washington
post
that says the mass shooting in colorado
is probably only one of scores that have
occurred
during your lifetime he says it is with
some grim irony that the united states
had relatively few mass shootings last
year the country had been averaging
about seven such events annually since
2012 using the washington post's
relatively conservative definition of
such incidents
as those in which four or more people
are killed in 2020 there were only five
but then much of the country spent a
decent part of the year isolated from
one another and out of school because of
the coveted pandemic
okay so number one if the country
averages seven incidents
annually this is according to the
washington post since 2012 in a country
of 330 million people
that does not present a systemic risk to
every american sufficient to justify a
gun seizure
on hundreds of millions of americans
obviously so instead
what you'll see is playing with the data
because there are certain places the
media can't go here
if they were to talk about the
generalized homicide problem in the
united states which actually is a
broader risk to americans they would
have to talk about the need for more
police that's not a solution they want
to talk about
if they were to talk about where the
risk of homicide is highest
they would have to talk about the fact
that it is not being driven by quote
unquote trumpian white supremacy
but that is being driven by gang land
violence and broken families
and real problems that exist in
america's major cities and that are
exacerbated by lack of police
that gun control in the middle of rural
america would not actually stop this
stuff so they pick a specific subset
a certain type of shooting and then they
declare that that type of shooting is
the highest priority to stop
for some yet to be explained reason as
opposed to the other 19 000 homicides
that occur every year in the united
states
and then they say that you are bad and
unsympathetic if you don't agree with
their solution
to a problem that on the list of
problems facing
everyday americans is not number one
it's not number two it's probably not
number ten
okay it is again every one of these
incidents is a tragedy that does not
mean
that the tragedy is sufficient to
justify the seizure of guns from some
hundreds of millions of americans or
banning the ability of americans to
obtain weapons to defend themselves
their rights and their families
so you will see a couple of tricks that
are played here one is the idea that
that europe doesn't have stuff like this
that you know europe doesn't have mass
shootings like this the united states is
the only place on earth that has mass
shootings
like this okay and
there is some level of truth to that but
not as much truth as the left would have
you believe
right the idea here is that somehow gun
control is the real
solution here well i mean that's not
true okay the reality is that some of
the safest states in america have
extraordinary levels of gun ownership
vermont has extraordinary levels of gun
ownership
very lacks gun laws and yet vermont
happens to have pretty much no murder
chicago has extremely onerous gun
regulations
and very high levels of murder
washington dc has extremely own risk on
regulations baltimore has extremely own
risk on regulations and very high levels
of murder
so the correlation just doesn't even
hold as far as that goes
okay but the washington post i mean by
the way phillip bumble will even
acknowledge this in paragraph
what six of this piece he says it's
important to maintain perspective mass
shootings are the cause of only small
percentage
of death in the united states and only a
small percentage of gun deaths most of
which are suicides
no other country experiences such
incidents at the same rate as the united
states and the shootings play a
disproportionate role in our culture
both because of the fear they invoke and
the complicated systems we've developed
to prepare for them
okay well but that's being driven by the
outsized media coverage one of the
things we do here at the daily wire
is we don't cover the names of shooters
because we don't actually want to
incentivize shooters who believe that
they're going to get famous off the back
of this sort of stuff i wish members of
the media would do the same
but it is i mean bump here is
acknowledging
that this is the number one story at the
washington post right is is the
importance of gun control
this particular shooting and the reason
for that
is because they want these shootings to
play a disproportionate role in our
culture because they justify the kinds
of policies that they're looking for
again if they were to focus on the
broader murder problem in the united
states they would recognize heavy gun
controls in major cities have not
stopped the murder problem
you know what stops the murder problem
in america's major cities which is
predominantly where these murders happen
more cops they don't want more cops they
want to defund the cops so
they've got a couple of priorities one
you can't have any sort
of reportage that leads to the
objectively true conclusion that we need
more cops you can only have reportage
that leads to the conclusion that
happens to be wrong
that gun control is justified and you
need an emotional response
that is broadcast on the air by pretty
much everybody because that emotional
response is an attempt
to say to everybody that if you disagree
with us it's because you just don't care
enough
again that two things can be true at
once the emotion can be genuine on the
part of the left and also
the the genuine emotion is rather
selective in its
in its application to particular
circumstances
so as philip bump says he says let's
conduct an experiment if you had to
guess how many mass shootings would you
estimate have occurred in your lifetime
have your guess now see how close you
were to the actual number the phenomenon
is pervasive both geographically and
across time
except that i'm sorry in a country of
330 million people seven incidents as
according to the washington post per
year that is not extraordinarily
pervasive
this is a country it's a country of 330
million people
you cannot say that incidents that
happened seven times a year on average
since 2012
are quote unquote extraordinarily
pervasive across time
in a country of 330 million people this
is not to downplay the evil
at all this is to point out the
statistical rarity of events like this
which is why they make the front pages
and this is all part of a broader agenda
right because the washington post has a
piece today
by adam taylor and amanda coletta same
same day as the philip
i mean they're right next to each other
on the washington post website
it says here's how other countries have
responded to mass shootings and of
course the answer is
they banned a bunch of guns because this
is what the media would like
the media are pushing this stuff
extremely extremely hard
in britain they have they decided that
they were going to
they were essentially going to collect
firearms the 1997 firearms act ended up
restricting ownership of
almost all handguns okay the washington
post isn't just reporting on this
because that's not new reportash
right happened in 1987 or 1997 rather
if it happened in 1997 it is by
definition not news
so now they're just reporting what other
countries have done to remind you that
we could do the same here and presumably
that would lead to this giant decrease
in mass shootings except for the fact
that the baseline level of mass
shootings in these countries was also
rare you hear this about australia well
look at australia's had a drop-off
in the number of mass shootings since
their massive gun buyback program won
only one-third of people actually turned
in their guns in the buyback program
and two the number of actual mass
shootings in australia
was statistically marginal in the first
place so any decline in the number of
mass shootings cannot be attributed
directly
to gun confiscation okay but this entire
washington post piece
is all about basically why gun seizures
are a good idea they say britain they
cite new zealand they say to australia
they cite canada but the idea is that in
the united states we just don't have
the the moral wherewithal to do all of
this it's not about the moral
wherewithal we have a different
calculation
of risk reward and rights in the united
states than than they do in many of
these other countries where the
government
is overbearing or public safety is um
in some cases much more problematic okay
for example the rape rates in
in great britain are apparently
significantly higher than they are in
the united states
in part because in the united states a
lot of women own guns you know i know
the great equalizer for women in the
united states it's amazing the same
people who will say that america has a
deep and abiding rape culture in which
women are in constant danger of men
wants to take guns away from women
you're going to have to explain that one
to me
it also happens to be statistically
untrue that the united states leads
the world in mass shootings according to
john miltomor writing
for the free enterprise for the
foundation for economic education
he says the he says the dominant
narrative
is that we as a country have to reckon
with the fact that mass violence does
not happen
in other advanced countries but that is
not right
john lot of the crime prevention
research center shows that the us trails
many other advanced nations in mass
shooting frequency as well as death rate
if you compare the annual death rate
from mass public shootings between the
united states and other countries from
january 2009
to december of 2015 norway ranks one
then serbia france macedonia albania
slovakia switzerland finland belgium
czech republic and then
the united states and when it comes to
the frequency of mass public shootings
the ranking goes macedonia albania
serbia switzerland norway slovakia
finland belgium
austria czech republic france and then
the united states
so yes the us rate is still high and
it's nothing to be extremely proud of as
investors business daily noted
but the reality is that mass shootings
do happen
in other places okay and a lot of this
is definitional
so the way that you increase the the bar
for how many mass shootings happen in
the united states is by decreasing
the number of people who are shot in a
mass shooting but the problem is once
you do that you then have to go into the
type of crime that is actually being
committed
if you if you set the numbers for mass
shootings at like two or three people
you're going to include a lot of gang
land violence and then that completely
screws up the left's narrative because
the left's narrative
is that is basically white people with
long guns who are committing a huge
number of these mass shootings
and on the homicide rate that actually
is just not true which ties into the
second narrative which we are going to
get to in just one moment
and the media jumped into this one i
mean completely unprepared for the
reality of the situation
and that is every mass shooting is a
white guy okay that is the other part of
this so the media has a
dual narrative when it comes to mass
shootings one it's
gun's fault two it's whiteness fault
we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about safety and security at your front
door so
this time of year got a lot of people
stopping by that front door you got
people working on your house if you got
people who are delivering packages
if you have people who are delivering
groceries so you've got a lot going on
on that front porch well here's the
thing if you're out of town or if you're
at the office you have no idea who's at
your front porch
you want to know this is why you need
your ring devices
a lot happens at our front or that's one
thing that definitely has not changed
at my house i'm getting a lot more
grocery drop-offs restaurant drop-offs
you know friends and family for the kids
i need to know who's at the front door
and this is why i have ring devices on
the home in fact when we move from
california to florida
first thing my wife said is get the ring
device on the front door also we have
ring devices around our house because i
have three children there's only one of
me they wake me up in ungodly hours and
then run around
as i basically sack out on the couch how
am i supposed to keep an eye on all
three of them
the answer is ring i love having the
ring video doorbell i've actually added
those ring security cameras around the
house as well you can see and speak to
whoever is at your door from anywhere
with video doorbells you can keep an eye
on every corner of your house with easy
to install indoor and outdoor cams you
can protect your whole home with ring
alarm a powerful affordable whole home
security system you can easily install
yourself
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit at ring.com ben
it comes the ring video doorbell 3 and
the chime pro it's the perfect way to
upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience head on
over to ring.com
again that is ring.com to get started
okay so in the aftermath
of this particular shooting in colorado
and remember this comes in the aftermath
of this shoot at this awful shooting in
atlanta where a white guy
shot eight people including six asian
americans and the media immediately
without any evidence declared this as
evidence of broader trumpian white
supremacy
again evidence that this is a hate crime
still completely absent in that
particular case
maybe it'll be found have been found yet
you'd figure
you probably have found it by now if you
were looking for it but
the media immediately jumped to the
conclusion after the colorado shooting
the identity of the shooter was not
immediately released to the media
now there's a pattern in the media and
the pattern in the media tends to be
that when the shooter is white this is
why conservatives held off on this
when the pattern when the shooter is
white the identity is immediately
released to the media generally
almost almost immediately like within a
couple of hours because
once the guy's in custody you got the
guy in custody so then it's just a
question of when
the police decide to reveal the identity
of the person in custody when the person
is non-white
not only will the police wait on
actually breaking the news the media
will then downplay exactly
the race or ethnicity of the person
because again all this plays into
broader narratives about what the
country should do
not with regards to things like
immigration or things like race god
forbid but what the country should do
with regard to things like more policing
what sort of measures should be taken
but for the left
because every problem in america can be
attributed to quote-unquote white
supremacy and whiteness
they immediately jumped into the story
and got the story completely wrong
you have to understand that for the left
right now whiteness is what atheists say
about religious people they call it the
god of the gabs so atheists will
frequently say about religious people
that religious people can't prove god
they can't prove that god exists so what
they'll do
is they'll look at the universe and then
if there's something unexplained they'll
say ah god
right so quantum mechanics happens and
it completely throws off
some einsteinian einsteinian theories
about how the universe works and
religious believers go ah god
and atheists will say no that's not god
you just don't understand how that works
and
god doesn't necessarily fill in that gap
right that's the god of the gaps okay
well
for the left they have whiteness and
white supremacy of the gaps
if there is a story they don't like they
just explain it with regards to
whiteness
we saw this with regard to
discrimination against asian americans
right if black americans are beating up
asian americans in disproportionate
numbers that is because of white
supremacy and america's systems of power
if asian americans
are succeeding too well in the system
that's because asian americans are
buying into systems of white supremacy
and if white people are targeting asians
asian americans that's also because of
white supremacy so no matter what the
grand unifying field theory of american
politics for the left is white supremacy
so they tried to apply this without
evidence
to the colorado shooting this was their
immediate jump they immediately jumped
into
this was a white guy because there was a
picture released and the guy looked
white
well turns out the guy's not white the
guy's actually syrian okay and it turns
out that mass shooters are not always
white in fact according to statista
of the 120 or so mass shootings in the
united states between 1982
and march 2021 about half of them are
done by white people
but the other half are not done by white
people
which is roughly the racial distribution
of the united states generally
and so that myth is just not true in the
first place that all mass shooters are
white
okay that is something that is
promulgated by the media because the
media wishes to suggest
that white people present the white
people with guns present the true threat
to the united states and blue check
marks jumped into this immediately
right they started jumping into this
like right away they started tweeting
out
over and over and over that the shooter
was white and this just demonstrates
that america is a white supremacist
country and also
because the police arrested this guy
after wounding him as opposed to just
shooting him dead
that's because they liked him the police
were racist
it doesn't matter that cop was actually
shot to death by the guy the police were
racist because they liked the white guy
but they never take the black guy alive
which is just a lie it is just overtly
untrue
okay but you have some commentary some
blue check julie decaro who wrote
extremely tired of people's lives
depending on whether a white man with an
ar15
is having a good day or not right you
have
alex cole tweeting out a white man
walked into a grocery store in boulder
not true
killed 10 people and was apprehended by
the police and walked out of the
building completely unharmed
right down the street police killed
elijah mclean while he apologized for
not doing
anything wrong okay again untrue
they thought that he was they thought
that they had to give him a drug because
he was responding
uh in in incoherent ways to their to
their commands
it may in fact be a homicide case i
believe it's being brought as a homicide
case right now but
what these two things have to do with
each other the answer is nothing kashima
rasheed esquire another blue check he
tweeted out
beyond infuriating that the colorado
terrorist killed a cop but was arrested
alive while cops shot tamir rice dead
for holding a toy because the cop feared
for his life
how's an unarmed black child more
frightening than a grown white male mass
murderer
reckless i don't understand were you
there
did did like what what
okay so this is just the narrative that
builds up every time right when when the
shooter in charleston
was of the black church right the racist
terrorist who shot up the black church
when he did that he was arrested and the
narrative was look at how the police are
treating him so nicely
well the police tried to arrest a lot of
people without killing them
if the police killed everybody who
presented a general threat to the public
there'd be a lot more dead people in the
united states
of all races but that doesn't that
doesn't matter the narrative has to be
promulgated the narrative is always
again
white supremacy is the answer even if
it's clearly not white supremacy as
we'll see in a second michael harriott
of the root who's just awful he tweeted
out
pointing out how white suspects get the
benefit of the debt without being
stopped first beaten shot or killed
is not a call for harsh treatment it
simply means we know cops are
capable of treating people humanely just
not us y'all could use a few more ass
whoopings though
he's just a bad person i'm sorry just a
bad person first of all
there is tape of white people being beat
to death by police officers
unjustifiably or shot unjustifiably
by the police in fact there are studies
done it says that
actually police tend to
disproportionately shoot white suspects
in dangerous situations as opposed to
black suspects
in situations and that does not matter
apparently at all
not only does that not matter it does
not matter that the suspect in this case
was not white the suspect kamala
harris's niece tweeted out about this
and actually had to delete
her own tweet about the white shooter
she tweeted out the atlanta shooting was
not even a week ago
violent white men are the greatest
terrorist threat to our country
terrorist threat to our country and then
she tweeted out i deleted a previous
tweet about the suspect in the boulder
shooting i made an assumption based on
his being taken into custody alive
and the fact that the majority of mass
shootings in the united states are
carried out by white men
okay so in other words you made an
assumption about some
shooting based on general racial
statistics
interesting interesting you should do
that
if you're on the left you can get away
with anything anything
by the way solid apology right there
that is not even an apology that's like
well you know i made an assumption first
of all
you know what the majority of people who
live in this country are white which
means that for virtually any stat you
can choose
the majority of people who do it are
white okay like
so the majority of people who eat hot
dogs in the united states are white
so i saw a guy eating a hot dog what
color was he well he's probably white
because
like what what what are you even talking
about
it's statistical statistical
incompetence okay so as it turns out all
of this immediately fell apart because
unfortunately for the left-wing
narrative about how whiteness is the
greatest threat
to america this particular gunman
happened not to be white
he was a syrian born person and not only
that
he ranted about islamophobes hacking his
phone he was apparently suffering
from mental illness the person's brother
told the daily beast he was very
anti-social and has been paranoid
since high school the brother describes
him as mentally ill
said he'd been bullied in school and was
not politically motivated
his sister-in-law said she'd seen him
playing with a gun recently but did not
suspect him of violence
and also he tweeted out a bunch of stuff
that was kind of supportive of isis over
the past few years
he tweeted out about how trump was
terrible right this this seems like a
mentally ill person
okay and rant he ranted about trump he
rants about refugees
he happens to be have been a muslim
although we don't know that islam was
actually the motivation in the shooting
it looks more like mental illness
but in any case this does not comport
with the fact pattern that the left
would like to promulgate
but that does not matter and the left
never acknowledges his own hypocrisy on
this score ilhan omar had just the best
set of tweets on this so illidan omar
tweeted out two things right so a week
ago
after the atlanta shooting ellen omar
tweeted out it isn't hard to understand
why it's so normalized for law
enforcement to protect
the humanity of white mass murderers and
their willingness to continually make
excuses for them
and then like a week later ellen omar
tweeted out the shooter's race or
ethnicity seems front and center when
they aren't white
otherwise it's just a mentally ill young
man having a bad day narratives drive
our responses to awful crimes committed
against innocent people pay attention to
these responses and who is targeted
literally a week ago she was targeting
you know the atlanta shooting as race
based
and talking about the race of the
shooter now you can't mention the race
of the shooter because if you do
then you're targeting people based on
race it's
unreal so notice something here okay
notice
that when the left uses racism as a
charge or when they bring up
white supremacy as a charge all of this
seems to be politically motivated
pretty much all of it it is it is a tool
they can charge their opponents with
racism and then be as racist as they
could
possibly want to be even if the evidence
doesn't back the position this is twice
in the course of two weeks that the left
got the narrative completely wrong and
it's still going to be random down
america's throat
in atlanta the narrative was that it was
white supremacy that was behind the
shooting and that it was connected to
trump and the wuhan virus and all of
this kind of stuff and it wasn't true
there's no evidence of it and then the
entire media jumped on the idea that
this guy was treated in colorado with
kid gloves because he was white and it
turns out he wasn't even white
again it's all about power whatever is
the brickbat at hand you have to use it
and because it's all about power and
because the democrats want
transformational change
they are now of course calling like
clockwork for gun control all right
we're going to get to
the actual call for gun control which
was inevitable it was going to happen
it's like clockwork
every time something happens left
immediately twist it to to their
advantage and to push their agenda
we'll get to that in just one moment
first if you haven't heard by now but
honestly if you listen to the show
you would have heard candace owens has a
brand new talk show with us exclusively
at dailywire.com
the full show might be available well to
daily wire members only but candace
is also a podcast you can listen to on
apple spotify
anywhere else you get your podcast the
canvas podcast features several breakout
segments from the full length show it
includes interviews panel discussions
for advice corner the podcast is so good
it reached number two on the apple
podcast chart just after the first
episode so
if you need some candace owns in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
so naturally the biden administration is
calling for gun control understand this
is all part of their broader pitch which
is that joe biden needs to rule the
world this this
this man who is falling apart this
administration
that has 50 plus kamala harris in the
senate
is going to try to ram everything they
possibly can through axios is reporting
that now joe biden you know captain
propriety you know
the lion of the senate this long
long-time institutionalist
he's now looking at nuking the
filibuster according to axios
president biden recently held an
undisclosed eastern session with
historians that included discussion of
how big is too big
how fast is too fast to jam through once
in a lifetime historic changes
to america four things are pushing biden
to jam through what could amount to a
five
trillion dollar plus overhaul of america
and vast changes to voting immigration
and inequality
one his full party control of congress
two his party activists egging him on
three
he has strong gathering economic wins at
his back and four he is popular
in the polls natural naturally
presidential historian michael buschloss
was a big government hack
told the axios that fdr and lbj may be
the closest
analogs to joe biden people close to
biden say he is feeling bullish on what
he can accomplish
he is fully prepared to support dashing
the senate filibuster rule to allow
democrats to pass voting rights and
other trophy legislation
for his party one because he loves the
narrative that he is bigger and bolder
than obama it's making him happy
the obama administration is ticked about
this by the way obama is unhappy at this
because he wants to be captain
transformation but it turns out that it
is biden
the old man who is coming in and just
showing him up
mitch mcconnell says this will create
such a fisher between the parties that
it'll be
nuclear winter but that's that's
basically right by the way that is
really not the risk the risk is not that
nothing gets done in the senate the risk
is that a bunch of stuff gets done in
the senate and that state governors just
say we are not going to go along with
any of this
you want to exacerbate the country's
national divides you want to make sure
that red states just stop helping out
the federal government
you want to make sure that the country
starts to fracture at all of its seams
do exactly what your biden is doing
right now and by the way do it on the
issue of gun control
if joe biden tries to nuke the
filibuster in order to cram down federal
gun control
in complete contravention of the
constitution of the united states
good luck if you think that citizens of
texas or alabama
or tennessee or florida are going to sit
still and let the federal government
tell them what to do with their guns the
federal government can have another
thing coming you want to exacerbate
conflict to the point of possible
violence that is the exact way to do it
see here's the thing that the left needs
to understand about gun ownership for
people who are not
of the far left in the united states it
is a fundamental right
in the united states to be able to
protect yourself including with guns
the reason to own guns is to stop people
from violating your fundamental rights
and the first sign that your fundamental
rights are about to be violated is when
someone comes to your door and demands
your guns
okay so this is a completely
self-defeating proposal nonetheless
this is exactly what biden is apparently
pushing for and now he's talking about
nuking the filibuster in order to do all
of this stuff
so jen sackey announced yesterday that
biden is considering executive action
on guns she apparently said putting in
place common sense gun safety measures
has been a passion of the president
since he was in the senate by the way
common sense gun safety measures that is
a euphemism for
gun control measures that have no
evidentiary backing
right like the 1994 assault weapons ban
which studies demonstrate did nothing to
stop mass shootings or to decline the
rate of homicide in the united states
apparently according to gensaki his his
position on the filibuster has not
changed as of yet but we are considering
a range of levers including working
through legislation including executive
action that has been under discussion
will continue to be
under discussion trobiden himself came
out and called for gun control yesterday
of course he did
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an hour
to take common sense steps that will
save the lives in the future and to
urge my colleagues in the house and
senate to act
we can ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
in this country once again i got that
done when i was a senator
it passed it was law for the longest
time
and it brought down these mass killings
we should do it again
no it did not bring down the mass
killings the evidence on that is scanty
to nil
okay and again watching this incoherent
president
try to push forward a massive gun grab
is pretty impressive stuff
now by the way the first the first
notion that you should have that the
government is about to invade your
rights is when they tell you they're not
about to invade your rights when they
assure you that they're not about to
come for your wallet they're coming for
your wallet and when they assure you
that they are not coming for your gun
pretty good time to start buying rifles
from bravo company manufacturing
before the government tries to make it
illegal to do so
so when vice president kamala harris
says don't worry you know they keep
saying we're coming for your guns
yes because you keep saying you're
coming for our guns that would be why i
remember when hillary clinton said this
in 2016.
in the 2016 campaign she was like they
keep saying that i want to come here
i don't want to come for your guns i
just want an australian gun buyback
program oh you mean the mandatory gun
buyback program in australia
where they came for the guns like that
here's kamala harris saying
you don't need to feel threatened all
we're going to do is you know massive
gun legislation
and i believe that it is possible it has
to be possible
that people agree that these slaughters
have to
stop and this is again reject the false
choice and stop pushing it for sure stop
pushing the fall's choice
that this means everybody's trying to
come after your guns that is not what
we're talking about
then who's go and i love that they're
part of that yeah yeah yeah yeah no but
then whose gun is you coming after
who's got like whose who's guns that
should be the question not what kind of
guns
who's guns because what i've noticed is
that you are not targeting criminals
right now they want felons to vote but
they want you the law-abiding citizen
not to be able to get a gun
this is the democratic agenda at this
point again the evidence that the 1994
assault weapons ban did a damn thing
is just not there according to the
foundation
for according to the foundation for
economic education
these studies demonstrate that there is
no evidence assault weapons ban reduced
the homicide rate between 1994 and 2004
the federal government banned the
manufacture sale or transfers
of assault weapons in large capacity
magazines a doj study found
no evidence the ban had any effect on
gun violence and stated it should be
renewed
the ban that should it be renewed the
ban's effects on gun violence are likely
to be small at best and perhaps too
small for a liable measurement because
again
if you are going to look at the kinds of
guns that are most frequently used in
homicides they are not long guns
they are not rifles and they are
certainly not rifles that are used
in mass shootings the number of mass
shooting homicides involving assault
weapons between 2007 and 2017
that's a 10-year period was 253 the
number of total homicides in the united
states was 150
000 the number of gun homicides in that
period was
hundred and four thousand 253
mass shooting homicides involving
assault weapons happened during that
period
so your notion is that you're gonna take
the 100 million
right they're 100 million long guns in
circulation in the united states and
that's what you're going to target
it doesn't even make any sense
again the the the notion that assault
weapons bans
somehow generated a a
an impact on the frequency of mass
shootings it's just not there
the the prior to the ban on average five
people were killed with assault weapons
in the mass shootings per year during
the ban the number went down to four
postband at roads to 22 but
mass shootings with assault weapons
didn't rise until 2012. that was eight
years after the ban ended
in the seven years after the ban there
was an average of four people killed in
mass shootings with assault weapons
every year
so maybe it turns out it's not the kind
of weapon that is the problem maybe it
turns out that it is a bunch of
different
factors that are the problem okay but
they have to lie okay they have to lie
about how easy it is to get a gun they
have to lie about the threat of mass
shootings in american society generally
they have to lie about the efficacy of
gun control generally because again
if you actually told the truth about the
efficacy of gun control you know where
you might be looking
chicago washington dc new york city l.a
and it turns out gun control there has
not been wildly successful
the only thing that is tamped down
homicide is heavy policing
it is precisely the opposite of the
policy proposals the left legs
okay so instead they just have to
maximize the the way that they talk
about the problem so you'll have chuck
schumer talking about the epidemic of
gun violence first of all gun violence
is not an epidemic
we actually have been through an
epidemic in the last year an epidemic is
defined
by the contagiousness and
transmissibility of something
gun violence is not transmissible it is
not an epidemic it is acts of individual
evil
those can be tamped down by adding more
police force to places that are high
crime
but the the what democrats are basically
trying to say is that the gun infects
you
the gun does not infect you it is a
piece of machinery it is a tool
but here is chuck schumer saying we're
going to address the quote unquote
epidemic of gun violence
republicans seem adverse to even wanting
to talk about the epidemic of gun
violence
like the start of the covet epidemic
their strat strategy is to downplay
and hope the problem goes away this
democratic-led senate will be different
the senate is not going to hide we're
going to debate and address the
epidemics
of gun violence in this country okay but
here's the thing
if you look at the number of homicides
in the united states over the past
30 40 years we've had an unprecedented
drop
in the murder rate an unprecedented drop
in the united states murder rate
since basically 1994.
and yet the idea is that we're now
experiencing this mass epidemic
of gun violence the national murder rate
in the united states according to the
death penalty information center the
national murder rate
in the united states in 1992 was
9.3 per 100
000 population okay it reached its highs
in about that period
it was really high in the in the late
70s and then kind of stabilized
and then its modern high was 1991 9.8
murders per 100 000 residents
currently in about 2016 2017 the lowest
it hit was about 2014.
4.5 murder it went in half in half
okay but the idea is that now it's an
epidemic and
again it is not an epidemic that's not
how epidemics work
but it's all a power grab and so they
have to lie so senator
padilla he says in a majority of states
is it alex padilla democrat of
california
he says in a majority of states it is
easier to obtain a gun than to vote this
is just an overt lie there's not a
single state in the united states where
it's easier to obtain a gun than to vote
i mean do these people know a damn thing
about how you obtain a gun
you actually have to go in to a
federally licensed firearms dealer and
then you have to show id
and then they have to run a federal
background check on you and if there's a
backlog you might have to wait a couple
of days while they actually run
the federal background check on you
that's at a minimum
okay when you go to register to vote you
show an id and you're registered to vote
and that's the end of it
here's alex video just overtly lying
there won't be a media matters fact
check on this guy
in 25 states voters must be registered
and have specific forms of id
in order to cast the ballot but those
same states allow people to buy rifles
without permits
and require no background checks for
some sales
additionally in the majority of states
new voters are
able to obtain a rifle quicker
than they're able to cast their first
ballot
it seems to me that we have our
priorities entirely backwards when it
comes
to this when we make it easier to buy a
gun
these geniuses let's put them in charge
of whether you can defend yourself
meanwhile dick durbin who once called
american soldiers akin to pol pot
dick durbin said loopholes make it
easier for felons and abusers to get
weapons
okay again the the
proof that these felons and abusers are
getting weapons because of quote unquote
loopholes
is extremely scanty very very scanty
doesn't matter don't need evidence you
just make assertions because assertions
are all the left cares about
here's dick durbin making the case there
are well-known gaps in the federal
gun background check system the gun show
loophole
the internet loophole and more
these gaps make it too easy for felons
abusers and mentally unstable people to
get their hands on guns
and harm others okay so first of all
there is no gun show loophole if you go
to a gun show they have to be a
federally licensed firearms dealer
they what is the so-called gun show
loophole is not gun shows
okay that's me conveying a gun to my son
in order for the government to prevent
that they would have to have
full-fledged gun registries for every
gun in the united states
which is something that no advocate of
individual liberty should be in favor of
but let's be real about this this is
basically in the end just an emotional
appeal
this is why you have victims of mass
shootings going on tv and saying that
the nra
is a terror organization and then every
member of the nra is apparently a
terrorist here's fred gutenberg who's an
anti-gun
activist he's a parkland dad saying this
on msnbc
they are a terror organization that is
making us less safe
you can't make up these things i mean
literally
six days ago the nra achieved its goal
and they called it victory for colorado
that's what they called it and here we
are
ten people dead including a police
officer because of what they believe
was victory for colorado okay except
that colorado already oh stop it
colorado already has universal
background checks red flag laws the city
of boulder for two years it only expired
six days ago which is what the nra was
talking about they had an assault
weapons ban
they had all of those things in place
again the evidence doesn't matter it's
the emotional appeal
and why don't we just we'll wreck the
filibuster and ram through gun control
that's what julian castro is now saying
he's saying filibuster reform to ram
through gun control
because the democratic agenda is the
only thing that matters and if you don't
have evidence to back it you just say
that people who
who oppose you don't care enough and
don't have sympathy for people who have
died in mass shootings
i actually think this is going to be
another indictment of the filibuster
uh how do you not call something
strongly bipartisan in this country
when almost 90 percent of americans
support it
and yet mainly one political party
stands
completely against it it doesn't make
any sense
and this is one more example of why in
the least
we need significant filibuster reform
that makes it
possible for effective meaningful
legislation like this
to to actually get enacted i mean this
is
i'm sorry these people are so it's so
ignorant i mean unbelievably ignorant
alison cameron just asked this morning
on cnn quote
how onerous would it be to have a gun
shop owner just say by the way are you
hearing voices do you think people are
chasing you do you think everybody is
watching you it would have weeded out
possibly this guy
yes i'm sure that if you want to weed
out criminals all you have to do is ask
them whether they're mentally ill that
would totally do it by the way you know
what gun shops have to do
i know because i just purchased a gun
the other day you know what gun shops
have to do they ask you
about your recent mental illness history
it's a thing they ask you
on the forums i again evidence is
unnecessary here all that matters that
they are
morally right and very emotional about
it and therefore you are bad if you
oppose their evidence-free agenda which
suggests that all the problems in
america are based on individual rights
and apparently on white supremacy or
whiteness or something
alrighty we have reached the end of
today's show but we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
the ben shapiro in the meantime go check
out the michael knowles show he's
discussing krispy kreme offering free
donuts for the vaccinated you can hear
more details about that story over on
michael's show that's available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam scievitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
terrible shooting in colorado raises bad
faith debate
a breakfast company gaslights a man who
found shrimp tails in his cereal
and a democrat senator won't vote for
white nominees check it out
on the michael knowles show
you